Daniel there it's my writing directing
partner simmer sweetheart Film Festival
this year will add Luna Toria and st.
James infirmary okay and we're really
what are the two films about okay when I
say blue Victoria's like a very almost
like it's a magical kind of romantic
fantasy very beautiful shot in Aruba and
this is the star actually buy you
Bennett okay so we actually co-directed
as ice covered in it and then we also
said music videos st. James infirmary
which is a kind of a fantasy as well
Sean New Orleans st. James infirmary the
song remains
so now how much time are you guys
putting behind the scenes because this
is all very glamorous and nice and you
get to come to the red carpet but how
much are you putting it behind the
scenes we don't see oh my god still
making our filmmakers a 24-hour job
seven days a week you know what I mean
and yeah I mean there's just a passion
activity there's no doubt about it but
you have like an amount of time they're
spending like can you tell us what are
they 24 7 47 okay we don't take off on
the weekend yeah we're sure we're not
only doing em you know we have our bird
I don't company but we're also writing
feature films right now if you're hired
with nancy cartwright boys have arts to
write a feature with her and she's are
some and Holly swords two years ago it
was like I love your writing here drive+
that's what we need more of so that's
we're doing right now nice and then you
to move from New York is that right not
the move well New York is like a really
inspiring city but it's so fast-paced
and there's just like it's just so
crowded and crazy that we love to LA you
know because industry is here and we're
actually thing called space and we like
that and how was that free of you when
did you finally say you know what okay
this is it i'm pulling the trigger we're
going to move I was that did you talk
about it and did you
my idea okay I said you like that we
need to go where the film industry is
and i said it's our mission you know we
want to make positive films and change
the world with art we moved here and
it's working beautifully we've been here
for a year and a half and working on
stuff oh great ok and then what's the
best an appendage on you seen for two
thousand it's gone in touchable French
film it's amazing you have to go see it
immediately ok I haven't seen it I
laughed non-stop I think it should win
the Oscar okay great and you know how
it's been coming back to all the shorts
you were here what 2010 right that's
right we love Molly shorts because these
guys do and Daniel are just incredible
they want to help filmmakers you can
travel to a lot of festivals in this
country and spend a lot of money but not
really get anything out of it but Holly
shirts you get so much out of being here
the contacts you know the media the
opportunity to screen a real movie
theater it's just these guys are really
really supportive of filmmakers
just real quickly how do you make a
decision which ones to submit to which I
litmus test sure example that year we
had in comedy so we looked at the film
festival over we're taking comedy and
and also you know what what what I
couldn't reach people never speak and
what happened award is it let's have a
thing that what is it qualify you for
also the reputation of accessible the
buzz about it all that just calling us a
basement yeah so you do your research
you don't just blindly hard for research
would you okay I'm at a box that's
wishes you guys